diese geschichte handelt von
straßenbahnschienen von einem picasso
von fjodor michailowitsch dostojewski
von einem theater von mir zähnen mit
viel viel geld und das alles in einer
kleinstadt am rhein die ohne mit szene
so wäre wie alle anderen kleinstädte am
rhein
der historiker peter habicht zeigt uns
ein paar der märchenhaften beispiele wie
mit zähne basels kultur bereichern das
schauspielhaus 17,5 millionen franken
mehr als die hälfte der baukosten
spendeten vermögende basler frauen die
anonym bleiben wollten
wie ein elefant wird basen bisher
unbekannt und das tram vor basels
musiksaal gleitet es wie auf leisen
sohlen weil eine mitziehen so wünschte
ein rumpeln gern
das hätte einen konzertgenuss bis
gestört und kristina tschenett wie eine
private medizin in drei millionen
franken bezahlt dass man die
tramschienen
doch an keinem ort wird die
verbundenheit der basler bürger zu kunst
und kultur so erlebbar
die im kunstmuseum durch das uns bringt
man der kurator der sammlung alter
meister führt durch die altmeister seele
gehen und auf den filmchen lesen auf den
wir jeweils die wunderbare herkunft
eines werkes angeben und vermerkten dann
werden sie unglaublich oft nachlass
vermächtnis und geschenk lesen zwei
sammlungen das ambacher kabinett 1662
von der stadt und der universität basel
erworben und die sammlung der familie
fesch bildeten den grundstock des
museums
diese zwei familien haben ein exempel
gebildet an die sich die baseler
bürgerschaft jahrhundertelang orientiert
hat und es gehörte in gewisser weise zum
guten ton
für das museum etwas zu geben
foto bringt man liest aus der
inventarliste des ama waschen kabinetts
ein toten bildet hans holbeins aus holz
mit ölfarben
eine liste mit meisterwerken diab 1671
im basler haus zur mücke ausgestellt
werden
die erste kunst sammlung der welt die
öffentlich zugänglich ist
schon damals ein magnet für
kunstinteressierte aus aller welt ins
museum in basel geht um den toten
christus von hans holbein zu betrachten
und der so beeindruckt ist dass er fast
einen epileptischen anfall vor dem wild
erleidet seine frau beschreibt das sehr
eindrücklich in ihren memoiren
das museum hat sich eingeprägt ins
bewusstsein nicht nur in das seiner
besucher es ist das museum der basler
bürger die 1967 mit einem bettler
festgeld für den ankauf zweier picasso
bilder sammelten so ist so friert sie
das erbe statt nur wie bilder geschenkt
hat und eine private mit denen die maya
sache dass ihre private sammlung im werk
st es ist eine diskrete elite die basels
kultur zu ihrer märchenhaften bedeutung
verhilft natürlich nicht ohne
hintergedanken denn auch mit zähne sind
nur mensch weiß innerhalb vor der
gesellschaftsschichten basis sehr genau
wer für was wie viel gibt also man
markiert quasi als die zugehörigkeit zu
diesem kreis
es ist die deutungsmacht oder medizin
etwas ist wird die kunst zum beispiel
und natürlich ist es eine selbst die
regierung des mädchens münchen-ost
hochwald eine andere erinnerung als was
natürlich der tag war im lager gezählt
und so wurde aus basel eine stadt die
sich sehr unterscheidet von
den anderen kleinen städtchen am rhein